With the polynomial 2 x squared plus 12 x plus 10, we got really lucky in how we
got to factor. Because there was a common factor of 2 between all three of these
terms. But you can imagine that for some polynomials, whose coefficients in
front of the x squared term aren't one, this won't be the case. Let's say for
example that we have an 11 here instead of a 12. Then we can no longer begin the
problem by dividing all the terms by this 2. So we're not going to end up with a
quadratic expression with a 1 in front that we know how to factor right away. We
need to figure out another method for factoring. I think we should backtrack to
the thing that we first started factoring with. Let's look at the general case
of a quadratic polynomial that's been factored, and whose leading coefficient
will be 1. We have x plus a and x plus b as our linear factors. Let's go through
multiplying this out again. I know we've done it many times before. Okay, so
multiplying this out we get x squared plus the quantity a plus b, times x plus
ab. What if instead of a and b we want to play with real numbers? But maybe in
playing with those real numbers, I want to keep the equation for the quadratic
in this form. Let's say we start off with a polynomial x squared plus 5x plus 6.
We know that we can rewrite this, recognizing that 2 and 3 are factors of 6 and
also add equal 5. As x squared plus, the quantity 2 plus 3, times x, plus 6.
Which pretty simply becomes x squared plus 2x plus 3x plus 6. Great. Now this
probably all seems simple leading up until now. But now I'm going to ask you to
do something a little bit different. The thing that I'd like you to do that
probably will feel a little bit strange is look first at just the first two
terms here. And find a factor between the two of them that's in common. Pull it
out and then write the rest of the equation in here, and then do the same thing
for the second pair of factors. Find a common factor and factor it out. And then
the expression you have after that, right here.